[Musique]
dénoncer la proposition de loi sécurité
globale énormément
ah oui la cyber games
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est 15 heures à paris et comme dans
tout le pays ce sont des milliers de
manifestants qui se sont rassemblés pour
protester dans un climat de tension très
forte avec les autorités depuis plus
d'une semaine c'est dans la rue que se
dresse l'opposition à une série de lois
dites liberticide et qui place la
liberté de la presse et les libertés
individuelles au coeur du débat public
le monde nous regarde quand toutes les
institutions internationales que ce soit
à l'onu l'europe etc condamne la france
est à l'air sur cette loi liberticide
un débat public avivée par détention
directe avec les journalistes mais
également par des débordements comme le
passage à tabac récemment du producteur
de musique michel est clair condamnée
fermement par emmanuel macron on a vu
malheureusement avec l'actualité récente
de cette semaine que la volonté de
cacher d'un visibiliser les violences
policières fait que ce qu'on a vu ces
derniers temps serait passée sous
silence
aux yeux de la population de l'opinion
publique à l'ars en démo ici sur le
terrain pour partir à la rencontre de
ces manifestants et en apprendre plus
sur la protestation
[Musique]
la proposition de loi dite de sécurité
globale c'est elle qui cristallise les
protestations
de nombreux français depuis un an
plusieurs semaines adopté par
l'assemblée nationale en première
lecture le 24 novembre
elle a suscité l'inquiétude et la
protestation des journalistes mais
également de la société civile elle
suscite aussi l'inquiétude de nombreuses
organisations qui comme le conseil des
droits de l'homme de l'onu la commission
européenne mais également amnesty
international ou encore la ligue des
droits de l'homme c'est un texte que
vous l'avez dit monsieur le président
qui vise également à renforcer la
protection que nous devons aux forces de
sécurité et ont échangé le monde contre
l'allemagne ainsi que des global mais
contre l'autoritarisme en général aussi
je pense que l'opinion
nous donner et qu'elle les prisons
et que c'est un lieu conçu c'est pas
seulement manifeste agile
je pense que tu te tais toi de sécurité
globale et le papa simplement
déjà parce qu'elle est votée dans un
contexte où les gens sont absolument pas
l'attendre et du coup ils profitent du
contexte pour l'affectation à ce moment
là et que c'est vraiment un moyen de
tirer les cardiologues sécuriser encore
plus mais tout est finalement en
protégeant la police car les manèges la
police sépare les deux démocrates
donc je voudrais d'abord souligner la
totale conviction qui est celle du
gouvernement et singulièrement la mienne
élevés au lait de la république de la
grande et belle liberté de la presse du
côté du gouvernement quand on écoute par
exemple gérald darmanin
il explique que les journalistes font
leur travail qui n'aura votre problème
qu'est ce que c'est cette déclaration
elle vous rassure ou pas
juste le monde la semaine on a bien vu
que c'était paris avec le journaliste
qui ont été brutalisés
on a ils ont beau crier press press
avoir presque partout sur leur visage et
sur leur répond c'est pas vrai
dans les yeux
il ya déjà suffisant
loi et de textes réglementaires pour
tout encadré il n'y a pas besoin
parce que j'observe ma petite échelle
des citoyens c'est
l'analyse brut finit pas sur les lieux
au moment des migrations
demande effectivement inhumainement de
la place de la république avec
l'ischémie par cycle a molesté alors que
c'est ma petite la presse et que ces
endroits en france toute la liberté la
presse pour
juste avant leurs relations avec les
médias
voilà formation de neuf et oui
évidemment et la plus solennelle vague
tu n'as pas l'information ils font tout
pour cacher l'information
on pousse dans cette loi plusieurs
articles très controversé à commencer
par l'article 24 qui modifie la loi sur
la liberté de la presse de 1881 pour
réprimer pénalement le fait de diffuser
dans le but qu'il soit porté atteinte à
son intégrité physique ou psychique
l'image du visage ou tout autre élément
d'identification d'un agent des forces
de l'ordre ces films et les forces de
l'ordre de viendrait conclure histoire
al'inverse la prise d'image car leurs
services
est facilitée et renforcer l'article 20
élargi ainsi leur accès aux images de
caméras vidéo surveillance le 21 prévoit
lui que l'enregistrement des caméras
individuelle des forces de l'ordre
puissent être transmises en temps réel
au poste de commandement dans le cadre
du maintien de l'ordre
l'article 22 lui aussi contesté
introduit la possibilité d'effectuer des
prises de vues par drones à des fins de
maintien de l'ordre
enfin d'adapter images l'article 25
autorise policiers et gendarmes
hors service à accéder à des
établissements recevant du public avec
leur arme de service
[Musique]
wakeham certaines scènes qui sont filmés
100k police qui sache mais qu'en fait il
n'y avait pas eu la vidéo tout
simplement les personnes auraient pas si
à tous les candidats papilles avant
leurs droits défendit
on peut savoir que maintenant on a
besoin d'être filmés pour être protégés
et que les perceptions les arbres dans
notre pays y sont potentiellement celle
qui nous tape dessus on a vu que
les images diffusées c'était
rapport de force en faveur des gens qui
étaient systématiquement 2
et agressé et qu'ils ne pouvaient pas le
prouver qu'on croyait jamais et là bas
on veut renverser renversé rapporteur
le fait que les policiers puissent à
avoir ces images plus même c'est pas
très clair s'ils vont pouvoir les
modifier et c'est assez clairement pour
tours compris le rapport de force qui
les merdes
avec avec toutes ces images qui s'occupe
la loi dit de sécurité au bal n'est pas
le seul texte de critiquer ici par les
manifestants dans le viseur également
ceux ci le nouveau schéma national
maintenant rendue publique le 16
septembre 2020 cet ensemble de mesures
renforcent certes le contrôle et
l'encadrement du travail des forces de
l'ordre comme par exemple pour l'emploi
de l bd deux grenades de désencerclement
ou de la stratégie de la nasse
mais il aborde aussi la prise en compte
des journalistes et de leur travail dans
le cadre du maintien de l'ordre
ce qui n'a pas manqué de susciter de
nombreuses protestations notamment de
journalistes
de la rédaction du
aujourd'hui pour moi
pour défendre
valeurs là et défendre aussi
laliberté travailler correctement
quatre emplacements
c'est intéressant il ya un peu plus
d'une semaine sur la place herriot
lors du premier rassemblement des
journalistes on voyait des journalistes
y filmer des journalistes pour vous en
tant que membre d'un média qu'est ce que
ça fait descendre dans la rue avec une
pancarte cette fois ci
paquette
quelque chose s'est pas vraiment inanité
nord
là on est d'accord sur tout
défendre
droit de travailler
droit de pouvoir
tu apprends dire nos valeurs
tous directement se trouve pas en tant
que personne c'est toute une profession
c'est
liberté de la fesse
des passes c'est pour ça que
droit de venir
on nous prive de plus en plus de l'eau
droit d'exercer de manifester librement
aussi bien les ong que les jours
liste c'est vrai que c'est un métier de
béquilles devient difficile aujourd'hui
l'analyste et pour manifester revenir à
ça à la maison c'est pas évident en
cause principalement un rappel que
précise ce schéma selon lequel le délit
constitué par le fait de se maintenir
dans un attroupement
après sommation ne comporte aucune
exception y compris au profit des
journalistes ou de membres
d'associations
les journalistes peuvent ainsi être
interpellé en manifestation un schéma
national du maintien de l'ordre
un store et je cite la canal des changes
dédié soit mis en place tout au long de
la manifestation avec les journalistes
titulaires d'une carte de presse et
accrédité auprès des autorités
le rappel de ceux ci les journalistes
couvrent des manifestations notamment
profondément aux schémas tableaux
évoqués ils doivent se rapprocher des
autorités en l'occurrence du préfet du
département
16h54 été plus de paris pour se signaler
pour être protégé également parlé par
les forces de l'ordre pour pouvoir être
distingués pourquoi rendre compte de
votre travail de journaliste dans ces
manifestations
là encore la mesure n'est pas passé
auprès de la profession car la question
d'une accréditation suscite de vifs
d'esprit
par ailleurs rappelons que la carte de
presse n'est pourtant pas obligatoire
pour être journaliste aux manifestations
et sur le terrain ce n'est pas forcément
impliqué
[Musique]
énormément aujourd'hui à oui j'insiste
quelque chose et entre aussi à autant
moore séduit les forces de police sont
pas très présents et ça c'est vachement
bien puisque ça permet quand même qu'on
puisse dire ce qu'il a sur la patate
c'est la première fois que sportivement
car question ça fait du bien de sentir
qu'on a droit à la parole
on est là pour exercer notre droit
constitutionnel dans notre liberté
de manifester également
puis se pensent que cette journée est
marquée par tous les événements qu'on a
eu cette semaine
le prix de l'air est à 135
nos fins à cacher
[Musique]
15h55 la manifestation était à la pêche
de 14 heures nous ne sommes nous pas
arriver sur la place de la veille
vous voyez derrière moi un incendie a
été lancée et des drones commence déjà à
survoler la manifestation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est trop bon ça fait un peu plus
d'une heure que le démembrement
commenter ici
nous allons tourner la place de la
bastille et vous voyez derrière eux et
bien une illustration des tensions
j'ai fait aborder ce reportage vous
voyez une boîte a été attaquée de
plusieurs reconnaissent également encore
magasin bmw est dévoyée de cette
illustration directe de cette petite
soeur qui se montre depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines contre les forces de
l'ordre avec est bien ici le seul
traditionnel but de la lutte
anticapitaliste observé souvent en
faible portée
[Musique]
enfin plusieurs heures sur place et
l'avertît que des tensions ont éclaté va
continuer avec de nombreuses fois dans
le monde jeunes qui ont pu assister avec
les intéresse beaucoup de dégâts
matériels sonar est ici à ce titre on
peut revoir puisque bien c'est une prise
de la bastille vers elle que vous
préparez les dix mètres des manifestants
bel et bien en rester là que l'aide de
william lady mond sera là tout le temps
on en a marre
[ __ ] quel usage social gare
[Applaudissements]
il est 19 heures 40 ça fait désormais
six heures que la manifestation a
commencé presse de la république ici
place de la bastille les derniers
manifestants assez sont évacués
progressivement alors du côté des
institutions
l'assemblée nationale a bel et bien
adopté ce projet de loi de sécurité
globale toutefois et bien il reste
encore le sénat doit l'examiner a
certainement en janvier moi je vous
donne rendez vous très rapidement sur le
terrain pour suivre la suite de cet
épisode le législatif qui a d'ores et
déjà marqué notre démocratie